on peut pas se tromper en appelant ses à
la semaine des budgets budget en
saskatchewan nouveau brunswick au québec
à ottawa et qui dit budget radio canada
10 ou 20 gérald fillion on est ici dans
le centre d'information à montréal on va
se diriger vers ce qu'on appelle le
module économie où travaillent gerald
suivez-moi gérald fillion bonjour
bonjour désolé de vous interrompre
alexine travail quotidien ça va bien ça
va bien grosse semaine semaine de budget
oui c'est la première fois qu'on nous
fait ça de nous faire ça deux jours
d'avis le fédéral 19 le provincial celui
du québec le 21 généralement quelques
jours une fin de semaine où des fois il
ya quelques semaines entre les deux
blonds le fait les deux dames
comme quoi chaque ça chaque année il ya
des variantes et combien d'années au
total général que vous couvrez des
budgets au fédéral et au provincial 2000
cap de médecins oui donc ça fait pas
loin de 15 ans fois deux budgets par
année sur une trentaine plus quelques
budgets et qui s'ajoutent les années
d'élections donc au moins une trentaine
c'est considérable et c'est ce qu'on
voit aussi derrière vous la bibliothèque
où chacun de ses livres représentent un
budget qui était directeur général
provincial budget 2006 des conservateurs
c'est le premier des conservateurs le
budget 2016 premier des libéraux oui
surtout de regarder ce n'est pas très
très minces de très minces alors que le
dernier de l'état au était pas mal plus
dense pas mal plus épais mais ça veut
rien dire ça non la grosseur du budget
devait revenir sur son contenu sur la
qualité de son contenu
parfois il ya un budget plus m'inspire
beaucoup beaucoup d'informations c'est
un budget fondateur pour un gouvernement
et parfois il ya des budgets très expert
on dit pas grand chose on se répète
énormément puis on cherche les nouvelles
monsieur flaherty au fédéral vous avez
fait une année sans nouvelles ou la
grosse nouvelle c'était la disparition
de la scène noire du sou noir ou
l'impressionnant plus grosse nouvelle
c'est presque pas une nouvelle
budgétaires alors ces grosses briques la
voulait décortiqué avec votre équipe
point quitte ici autour de vous et et
tout ça c'est au coeur de la préparation
lacarne absolument on est dans le huis
clos je suis avec mon collègue nicolas
david
avec qui je travaille au quotidien
depuis un bon moment déjà et qui
creusent le budget avec moi qui écrit
des choses est un économiste un
fiscaliste il ya toute l'équipe d'ottawa
ou de québec quand on va et tout le
monde participe au huis clos
tout le monde participe au huis clos il
ya des journalistes y ait des experts de
différents groupes de la société qui
sont là également on peut poser des
questions aux ministres au président du
conseil du trésor également sur place
donc c'est vraiment un endroit qui est
fermé parce qu'on ne peut pas divulguer
l'information sérieux et la police
exactement la police est là avant la
levée du ministre en chambre du ministre
des finances après la fermeture des
marchés parce que des informations
sensibles
alors ça prend ce huis clos pour passer
à travers préparer des textes préparés
des tableaux préparer des extraits se
prépare est capable d'expliquer de
budget et de voir toutes les petites
subtilités ans a souvent ce qu'on
découvre dans tout ce qu'on dit très
dense il ya parfois de la petite perle
rare
oui mais on le voit pas toujours vers
joueurs mais c'est parce que des fois ça
la page 323 dans le 4e paragraphe sur
une information et une année où on avait
le gouvernement harper avait commencé à
baisser les crédits d'impôt sur les
fonts travailleurs et on s'en était pas
rendu compte en le lisant ces tests et
en chinois pratiquement est finalement
plus tard dans la journée un expert qui
nous nous voir il dit je pense que c'est
ça que ça dure et ça avec les beaucoup
de remous et donc des fois on se
rencontre plus tôt dans la journée ou le
lendemain grosse grosse semaine oui
vous l'attendiez avec impatience ben oui
oui on est parti ça fait partie du jeu
du travail merci beaucoup géré ça me
plaisait à l'équipe au travail
oui ça s'est vu